if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to two hundred
dollars off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
pacman
welcome to the david pakman show i am
farron cousins i will be sitting in for
david pakman all of this week we've got
a lot of stuff to cover today everything
from buildback better to the january 6
select committee a bunch of lawsuits to
talk about fox news michael cohen and
donald trump himself
so let's jump right into it obviously
the biggest news to come out over the
weekend is build back better
we went into this weekend with the
assumption that buildback better was
effectively on its deathbed
the democrats had said we're not going
to be able to pass it before christmas
like we had wanted to
then
talks broke down between joe manchin and
joe biden
and then on sunday morning
joe manchin goes on of course fox news
to let us know that nope
it's dead
there's nothing
that he can justify in this bill he says
to vote for it here is joe manchin in
his own words appearing on fox news
sunday morning
to tell us why we can't have nice things
take a look
i've always said this brett
if i can't go home and explain it
to the people of west virginia i can't
vote for it
and i cannot vote to continue with this
piece of legislation i just can't
i've tried everything humanly possible i
can't get there
you're done this is this is a no
this is a no
on this legislation i have tried
everything i know to do
and the president has worked diligently
he's been wonderful to work with so in
spite of the fact
that this bill is broadly supported
across the country including in west
virginia
in spite of the fact that this bill
would provide tangible benefits
to millions upon millions of americans
again including his own constituents in
west virginia would make people's lives
better would allow low-income families
to have food for their children
i mean literally that's one of the
provisions in the bill by the way if you
weren't aware of that one that's an
often overlooked one would provide money
for families to get food for their
children over the summer when schools
are not in session and they can't get
those meals
and manchin says no i i just i can't
justify this there's nothing i can do
i've looked at it every which way and
biden's been so great to me in the
negotiations but dang it
i i can't make the country a better
place is what he's telling us i can't
make the country
any better than it is
and of course after this appearance on
fox news his office did release a
statement and one of the things he
highlighted in his statement that he
personally released
was that it just transitions us
off of fossil fuels a little too quickly
for him
he didn't mention of course that he owns
a stake in a
dying coal company
just said nope is a little too quick for
us
to get on the renewable energy bandwagon
you know to revamp our energy structure
here in the united states to actually
help us
handle renewable energies nope just too
quick too much adds too much to the
deficit he tells us
would uh send inflation soaring which is
based on a faulty cbo score based on a
fraudulent bill by the way that
republicans sent to the cbo for scoring
that included things that one weren't in
the build back better act and it
extended provisions that are not
extended in the build back better act so
the republicans and joe manchin use this
as his justifications send this
fraudulent bill to the cbo thereby
getting a fraudulent score on it
showing all kinds of horrible things
that again couldn't happen because the
things they had in it weren't actually
in the bill
and joe manchin uses this knowingly
faulty piece of information
as his justification
for killing build back better saying i
just i can't i can't rationalize it i
can't justify it there's nothing i can
do
so
to hell with it
now he did
use a couple words in there that we need
to pay attention to he said this bill
this bill
so maybe that means build back better as
a whole or it could mean in its current
incarnation
so maybe joe manchin is signaling that
once they return from their holiday
break maybe he's willing to
continue working on it but i seriously
doubt that's the case i think joe
manchin
did send a strong message that he's done
with this bill
all together no matter what it does no
matter what kind of concessions that
president biden and the rest of the
democratic party make he is done
with build back better
which of course puts the democrats in a
really horrible position heading into
next year's midterms
because this was supposed to be the
signature piece of legislation right
okay we got infrastructure fantastic
a lot of the funding mechanisms for that
infrastructure bill are inbuilt back
better though
so there will be parts of the
infrastructure bill
that are not going to be able to be
fulfilled because the funding isn't
there because it was in buildback better
that's why the two bills were paired
together
it was supposed to come as a package
deal
and we only get
half of the bill
so that's going to be a big problem too
and again to do this in what is
effectively an election year because the
election is less than a year away at
this point
joe manchin is telling the democrats
so long and good luck
because this is going to come back to
haunt them
in the midterms
now there's things that are haunting
republicans and i'm going to get to that
later in the show don't you worry the
republicans have plenty of demons to
deal with on their own but right now the
democrats have to deal with their demon
and that is joe manchin and of course
there's everybody on social media has
got their personal opinion on it you
know a lot of people out there saying
mansion's just doing what the uh uh
establishment wants him to do that joe
biden is kind of glad that manchin did
this because he wasn't obviously
wholeheartedly supporting this
we can only speculate right
none of these people myself included
know exactly what the reasoning is
do we know that the corporate interests
want buildback better dead 100 percent
that's unequivocal
do we know for a fact that joe biden
you know doesn't really care about this
no we don't you can only speculate about
that and i don't like to get into that
kind of speculation
because it's not fair it's not accurate
honest reporting so we're going to avoid
the speculation
and focus on what is happening now and
right now
based on joe manchin's own words it does
appear
that build back better
is effectively
dead
another thing that is haunting the
democrats ahead of the 2022 midterms
joe biden's approval rating has taken
another major hit this time
among young voters those aged 18 to 30.
according to the latest round of polling
out there joe biden
now has a net negative 23 approval
rating with that particular age group
that for the record helped push him
past donald trump in the 2020 election
his disapproval rating with that age
group right now is 50
approval rating with that age group is
27 that's where you get the 23 net
difference between the two numbers
and that again is going to hurt joe
biden in the midterms and of course the
democratic party since joe biden's
clearly not on the
ballot there
but that age group
which does now
you know when you take the the
millennials
uh and the other age groups
they make up one of the largest voting
blocs in the country they are the
largest voting bloc in the country
so when they're looking at this
administration after putting you in
office just a year ago
and they're saying we're not happy with
what you're giving us because what
you're giving us is effectively nothing
then that's a big problem for the
democratic party that they're going to
have to find a way to overcome
prior to those midterms
one of the things obviously driving
factor in this decision to no longer
support joe biden with this age group is
the student loan debt
biden specifically promised and you can
still go back on his twitter feed and
see where he promised
ten thousand dollar student loan debt
forgiveness at the very least
ten thousand dollars
and it's not there
oh sure he has forgiven debt for some
people
but you've got to jump through so many
hoops in order to qualify for the debt
that has been forgiven so far
that it effectively amounts to what one
percent maybe of total debt held i think
it's actually lower than one percent
no that's not good enough you're not
going to win back over this age group
that is saddled with one and a half
trillion dollars of student loan debt
with
a one percent forgiveness for some
people who meet all of these you know
very strict criteria not happening and
for the record student loan debt does
not just affect that generation
you have people in their 60s in this
country that still have student loan
debt
you know obviously a lot of that is
because these people went to college
late in their lives
but
they're still paying this off this is an
issue that does affect every generation
here in the united states it is not just
the young voters
but specifically he promised them he
told them again it's still on twitter
you can go and see it for yourself
and he hasn't done it
and that's something
that he could do via executive order
now for the record too there's a lot of
people out there who say no he can't do
it via executive order a lot of people
who says yes he can do it via executive
order and the discrepancy between the
twos has to do with the public student
loan debt and the private student loan
debt meaning if you took out your
federal loans you know you did your
fafsa
and you got your student loans from the
federal government itself you know the
department of education that's what
biden could forgive now if you took out
separate student loans
because banks do offer those
that would probably take an act of
legislation
right i know i had a couple myself the
interest rates on those were absolutely
astronomical but luckily for me
the amounts i took out from private
banks were so small i was able to pay
them off you know within a 10-year
period not not quickly obviously but
those i did work to pay off first
because really couldn't get deferment on
those either and that actually
unfortunately is a lot of the problem
those private student loan debts
the ones with the higher interest rates
the ones with the stricter criteria in
order to get
a deference and forbearance
so that does take an act of legislation
but biden could for this age group at
the very least
give this executive order show them he's
doing something show them he understands
their concerns for the future
throw them a bone here
and it may just help to save democrats
in the midterms
but i also have to talk about one more
thing here
biden's done some good okay we can't
just sit here and say oh buildback
better is dead and biden's not doing
anything for young young voters whatever
it is because biden has done one thing
that is truly phenomenal that he is
unfortunately not getting enough credit
for
and i do believe in giving credit where
credit's due
and that is appointing federal judges
since the senate is out for the year now
biden in his first year in office has
gotten confirmed 40 federal judges to
lifetime appointments here in the united
states that is more than any president
in their first year in office since
ronald reagan
and by the way it's more than double
what donald trump got in his first year
in office
when he had the senate under republican
control
that's pretty remarkable
but it's not just the number that's
remarkable here
because anybody can appoint judges right
get the numbers up you look good but the
fact
is that a lot of these people that biden
has picked
are either coming from a background as
public defenders
or from plaintiffs law firms
and that's a huge difference from what
we even saw with president obama
president obama picked a lot of people
obviously with the liberal credentials
but they came from these corporate
defense law firms
and that's why even his administration
saw some of their rules struck down by
the very judges he put in place for a
lifetime because they benefited
consumers rather than corporations
these judges
depending on their background do
obviously have a bias you cannot say
that they don't they're not supposed to
but they do
and so picking
people who spent their careers
representing injured
people injured consumers
and now they get to be the judges that
is a massive step forward that is huge
for this country and again typically
this is not something that we see even
from democratic presidents
so joe biden president joe biden
deserves a ton of credit for what he is
doing with these federal judges
so far in year one that has absolutely
been the brightest spot of this entire
administration
i am farron cousins i'm sitting in for
david pakman follow me on twitter at
fair unbalanced and we'll be right back
with more
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is you
don't have to guess which mattress do i
need which one will be good for me you
take their famous sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you i took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what i needed i often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and i've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so
don't get stuck with something that's
not perfect for you and all helix
mattresses come with a 10-year warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days if you
don't love it but i think you will all
of my viewers will get up to 200 off
your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows for free
when you go to the link right underneath
this video welcome back to the david
pakman show i am fair and cousins from
ring of fire sitting in for david pakman
today don't forget you can follow me on
twitter facebook and instagram
at fair and balanced you can find me on
youtube at youtube.com slash fair and
balanced and of course the big channel
youtube.com slash the ring of fire
you know
according to the administration the
biden administration america is no
longer at war right
it's the first time we haven't
officially been at war in decades here
in the united states
but that's not true because there is a
war raging right now
and i'm not just talking about the
conflicts we're still involved in
overseas i'm talking about the war here
in the united states being waged by
republicans
the culture wars
the culture wars are pretty much the
only thing that republicans have to run
on these days
and
unfortunately they're doing a dang good
job of it
last friday evening on fox news host
tucker carlson spoke with right-wing
radio host jesse kelly where they
launched what is really a new avenue in
the culture wars that right-wing pundits
have been talking about for the last
couple months and that is the
emasculation
of the american military it's too
feminine
they say
because you know we've got women in the
military
we have members of the lgbtq community
in the military and
tucker carlson and jessie kelly just
can't stand it because apparently that's
the worst thing imaginable
here the two are talking about what they
perceive to be the problems and of
course they're terrifying solutions
for the us military take a look i mean i
don't know there's a psychological term
for this and it escapes my memory at the
moment but where there's a massive real
threat that you can't deal with so you
scurry off and deal with imaginary
threats to make yourself feel in control
that kind of feels like what we're
watching
well what we're watching is the
destruction of the u.s military and what
we're going to end up seeing tucker is
thousands tens of thousands maybe
hundreds of thousands of americans die
that's those are the stakes of the game
we're playing here we don't need a
military that's woman friendly we don't
need a military that's gay friendly with
all due respect to the air force we need
a military that's flat out hostile we
need a military full of type a men who
want to sit on a throne of chinese
skulls but we don't we don't have that
now we can't even get women off of naval
vessels that should be step one but most
of them are already pregnant anyway we
want
men who want to sit on a throne of
chinese
skulls
you know what's really interesting about
all this china phobia
that's going on with the republicans
right now if you were to go out and ask
the average voter the average
conservative voter what what's the
problem with china right what does the
u.s
really have against china why are all of
these republicans always talking about
china all the pundits china china china
none of them can tell you why
because it's a very convoluted and
ridiculous issue and this of course
builds upon donald trump's trade war
with china which for the record we still
don't have resolution for that either
i would love to hear more from the biden
administration about what they're doing
to undo that damage but
obviously they've got a lot of other
things to deal with but let's get back
to the military issue shall we
women
who volunteer
to go and fight for our country to sign
up to serve
the united states of america that's the
problem
first and foremost let's talk about this
is there a problem with the military are
we having an
issue where we can't win battles anymore
where we don't have the right equipment
where we don't have the right training i
mean is that a thing that's actually
happening because if it is i haven't
heard about this
i haven't heard about u.s troops just
getting absolute destroyed
in every conflict we're involved in
because of the women
or because of the lgbtq community that's
not a thing
okay that's the most important thing to
remember when we talk about this is it's
not real
the us military is not suffering
because
non-men are in there
or because transgender men are in there
transgender women
women
anyway like this is absolutely such a
ridiculous argument from these two that
it's almost hard to even
talk about it
because it doesn't exist it's not real
these are two absolute wimps
that can't help themselves but from go
around trying to act like we're the
biggest manly men ever and by the way as
tucker said last week and david talked
about covet apparently makes you
feminine
these people are the ones who are
obsessed with gender roles these people
are the ones who are obsessed with
pronouns and what you call other
individuals
more so than anyone on the left is
and of course that's another one of the
big ironies of this
they claim that the wokeness is so bad
you know that the pronouns are bad
that transgender individuals are bad
they're the ones who keep talking about
it oh the left only wants to talk about
this let's do 800 segments on it
throughout the day
no
y'all are obsessed with this
we just say hey if somebody says call
them this call them that
show them respect let's protect them
with legislation because they are being
absolutely targeted
you know we see that in suicide rates we
see it in murder rates homicide rates
all of that
this is a community that does absolutely
need legislation protecting them
but if you want to talk about which
party is going out there and endlessly
ranting about it that's on the right
that's not the liberals that's not the
left it's not the democrats it's not the
progressives
it's the republicans who seem more
obsessed with what is in somebody's
pants
than they do with real problems that are
actually threatening the united states
today that's what that's what i'm taking
away from that segment
but we also have to remember
the chinese skull comment right
that that's horrifying
we don't want members of the military
who are bloodthirsty psychopaths
but that appears to be at least in my
opinion you know my my takeaway from it
what jesse kelly is saying we want
people that want to go out there and
just kill as many people as possible
and i know a lot of folks think that
that's what the military is supposed to
be
the military is supposed to be about
protection
the military is supposed to be about
fighting when fighting is the only
possible way forward
that's the way it was you know
throughout history sure of course you
had people that abused it obviously they
used it for takeovers
but here in the united states we're not
taking anything over
our military is to protect us
not to go out there and expand the
american empire although
clearly we've got plenty in power that
would love to see that happen
we don't want a bunch of blood thirsty
crazy people
out there running around the globe
killing people because they think that's
what conservative pundits
want them to do
so that
you know attacking the not more uh manly
u.s military
is apparently one of the new avenues in
the republican right-wing culture wars
but let's not forget the big one right
now
the big avenue in the culture wars for
republicans is of course critical race
theory critical race theory which most
of them can't even define they have no
idea what it actually means
but they hate it
and they're doing everything possible to
make sure this is not taught in schools
even though it's already not taught in
schools
and florida's republican governor ron
desantis became the latest republican
last week to take aim
at this imaginary foe to conservatism
by signing a bill called the stop woke
act
and the stop woke act prevents schools
here in the state of florida from
teaching critical race theory
even though it wasn't a thing that was
taught you can't even hint at
in schools now because of this
legislation that there was ever any kind
of racism in the united states justice
system
which means i guess no more talking
about slavery no more talking about jim
crow no more talking about lots of
portions of the united states
constitution
so i don't know what kids are going to
be learning in history classes here in
florida because it sure as hell isn't
going to be american history anymore
because desantis has made it to where if
you find out that your child
is being taught critical race theory
in public schools here in the state of
florida you can sue the school district
that's what he's doing you the parent
can now sue that school district
which gets funding from this state
which
desantis runs so i i guess in a way
you're suing ron desantis
if your child learns about american
history yeah he didn't really think it
through
because that's not what ron desantis
does he doesn't sit there and think
things through ron desantis is only
thinking about one thing and that's when
is he going to be able to run for
president of the united states
this is just the latest
in legislation signed by florida's
republican governor ron desantis this
year
about culture war issues
that's all the man knows how to do this
state is absolutely dying from covid and
most of them are republicans
62 000 i think were up two deaths in the
state of florida from covid
with omicron out their numbers right
back going up again just like they are
all over the country
and ron desantis biggest concern is
critical race theory that's already not
being taught something he doesn't even
define in the legislation so
of course it's going to open the door
for any right-wing parent to sue a
school district if their kid comes home
and says hey we learned about
martin luther king today hey we learned
about
slavery today parents can say wonderful
i'm going to go call my lawyer and we're
going to put an end to this
now it's unlikely that the legislation
obviously is going to hold up in an
actual court
but by the time we get to that we will
have seen countless lawsuits here in the
state of florida filed against public
schools
we're going to drain them of resources
which they likely will not be able to
get back
and that's going to put the burden back
on the state
when these school districts even if they
win the lawsuits right they're still
going to have to pay all the legal fees
lawyers ain't cheap folks
and we're putting it on our already
underfunded school districts
so even if they win they're going to pay
tens of thousands of dollars to defend
themselves in court
where are we going to make up that money
again
either they're going to have to raise
taxes on florida residents
which we know republicans who control
the state refuse to do
maybe they'll do it because it's on
regular constituents and of course not
corporations of the wealthy elite
or we're just going to have to eat the
costs and sacrifice elsewhere in the
schools
there's no good outcome for this is what
i'm getting at here for the state of
florida in our public school system
either we end up with even worse
underfunded schools here in the state
or we end up with an entire generation
of children that is completely ignorant
about the real history of the united
states
neither one of those outcomes are good
they're both very very bad
but that's what ron desantis is doing
because he is now the king of the
republican culture wars
he's the general on the ground fighting
these wars for them
and he's attacking things that don't
exist and like i said this is not the
first one he's done this year he also
signed the transgender athlete ban
oh no no transgender women
can't play women's sports here in the
state of florida transgender men however
can still play men's sports
neither of those things are an issue
though neither of those things have
caused problems we have a lot of college
football here in the state of florida we
have a lot of pro football here in the
state of florida
three major nfl teams
three major college teams
and a lot of secondary college teams as
well
and that's just football alone
and not once has there ever been any
kind of uproar over a transgender man or
transgender woman
attempting to play these sports and
having some kind of unfair advantage but
ron desantis knew that he could get his
republican base riled up about it and of
course distract from the fact that
people are dying in this state left and
right from covid
so it's a two-prong
victory for him really
he gets the pander to the worst people
in the state and he gets to distract
from his horrendous handling of the
coveted 19 pandemic and again he's doing
a dang good job of it nobody is fighting
the culture wars as hard as ron desantis
and of course what's on the horizon for
us
an abortion ban modeled after the one in
the state of texas too
i am fair and cousins find me on twitter
instagram facebook at fair and balanced
we will be right back with more on the
david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today and if
you've enjoyed me don't forget you can
subscribe to my youtube channels
youtube.com slash fair and balanced and
of course youtube.com slash
the ring of fire
let's get into some legal news right
we've got a lot
of lawsuits a lot of legal issues
bouncing around out there right now
so let's jump right into one of the big
ones late last week a judge ruled
that fox news could not
get a dismissal of the defamation
lawsuit filed against them by dominion
voting systems
fox had gone into court and they had
attempted to argue listen we are a major
news outlet
we were reporting on what was happening
in the news at the time as we are
entitled to do we have a first amendment
right here
and of course some of the folks it was
opinion so you can't take that as facts
so therefore based on those arguments we
would like for this case to be dismissed
now before i get into the what the judge
said about that let's not forget
dominion is suing fox news for 1.6
billion dollars which is more than the
1.3 billion dollars most of the
individuals are facing in this lawsuit
but dominion is arguing that fox news
knowingly allowed these lies to go on
their network unchecked
even though they knew they were false
fox news in the past has used those same
legal arguments that i just mentioned to
get out of a lot of legal trouble
in fact it wasn't that long ago they
successfully argued that tucker carlson
can't be sued for defamation slander
libel because you know he's an opinion
host and as they put it in court their
lawyers did no reasonable person
would take what the guy says seriously
and so fox came to court and again
that's not the only time they've used
that and won on it
so fox came to court probably a little
little arrogant you know thinking look
we got this we do this all the time
we're good at this we're we're old pros
watch us handle this and the judge said
nope
not going to happen
the lawsuit's moving forward and you
know why
the judge says
judge says the case is moving forward
because
you should have known that these claims
you were making on the air were false
you either had information
that said these claims were false and
chose to ignore it
or you failed to do your
due diligence excuse me
and verify these claims before you went
on the air with them
so the lawsuit moves forward
but at this point do we even need it
the judge
kind of just gave up the game right
the judge says listen you should have
either known they were false you did
know they were false or you didn't even
bother to check
so you either have negligence not
checking which is going to get you a
negative jury verdict or you have actual
malice
which is going to award dominion a major
ruling
so which one is it because the judge
basically says like that's pretty much
what you have you know if we use our
legal knowledge and extrapolate from
what the judge said that you either knew
they were false and went with it anyway
actual malice or you just didn't bother
to check which is negligence
both of those could result in a judgment
against fox news one of them the actual
malice being much much bigger much more
serious
so what are fox's options at this point
either go forward allow the case to
proceed
allow the case to go through discovery
and see that's the part fox news doesn't
want
you go through discovery
then suddenly your emails your text
messages your phone calls your producers
communications with these guests
the information the guests send to you
that's all going to come out
that's all going to be handed over to
dominion and their lawyers
and of course as we always see it's
going to become public
fox news can't allow that to happen they
won't allow that to happen
so my best prediction at this point and
of course this is what other legal
experts are are predicting
fox is going to end up settling
and given the fact that dominion is not
going easy on any of the individuals
they're suing for defamation
fox news is going to end up paying
through the nose for this most likely
if they allow this to go to court
based on what the judge ruled last week
it's unlikely that fox news would be
able to prevail
so they will have to settle and knowing
that they're already in a bad situation
where a jury trial would likely not go
their way dominion has the upper hand in
any settlement talks
so dominion could easily say all right
we'll settle right now billion dollars
no less you want to go to court you're
going to pay us 1.6 plus you're going to
pay a lot more in legal fees and we may
even be able to get our legal fees from
you as well so you make your choice
we don't know we don't know how much
dominion would ask for in a settlement
but it's likely going to be a lot
and fox news does have the money to pay
it and believe me
in terms of
accountability for the network
it's much cheaper for them to pay a
massive settlement
than it is to let all of their internal
communications about the big lie
become public because that
is going to cost them more than anything
else
another legal story that popped up over
the weekend
the republican party itself the rnc
has agreed to pay 1.6 million dollars
worth of donald trump's legal fees
for the ongoing investigations taking
place into trump in the trump
organization
in the state of new york
now the washington post broke this story
and they described it as a highly
unusual move
after all donald trump is not a
candidate right now
he he's not even a representative of the
rnc
he's not a sitting politician he's just
a retired guy sitting in florida playing
golf and the republican party has
decided to step in and say hey you know
what
we understand you got some bad things
happening up in new york how about we
help you out a little bit right how does
1.6 million dollars sound for your legal
fees mr billionaire
that's the part that really blows my
mind about this is doesn't donald trump
have an estimated net worth of like 10
billion dollars
10 billion 1.6 million that's nothing
for him
of course trump will take it
you know he he would love for everybody
else to pay his legal fees so he doesn't
have to spend the dime on it but
why would you even need to pay a
billionaire's legal fees
maybe he's not actually worth a billion
i don't know i haven't seen his
financial statements
prosecutors in new york have
so that's going to be fun
but
this is highly unusual right the
washington post is correct this is a
highly unusual move this is not
something that happens all the time this
hell this isn't something that happens
so this is weird why would the rnc step
in and agree to pay this billionaire's
legal fees for an issue that's not even
related to politics in an investigation
that technically hasn't even accused
donald trump of any wrongdoing at all
nothing about this makes any sense
because again trump has not even been
accused of anything
this is an issue that doesn't involve
politics
but the rnc came out
this is via gop spokesperson emma vaughn
who said quote as a leader of our party
defending president trump and his record
of achievement is critical to the gop
it is entirely appropriate for the rnc
to continue assisting and fighting back
against the democrats never ending witch
hunt and attacks on him
so even though it's not political
they've gone and made it political
because that is their political strategy
see now we're kind of getting to the
heart of what's actually happening here
republicans the republican party itself
the establishment of it
has decided if trump's gonna be our guy
we gotta protect our guy
and if he's gonna be the guy that
the next person latches themselves onto
and models themself after we still have
to protect him
because if his
empire if his image
that he has created gets destroyed
then we get destroyed
we have become inseparable from this man
so we do have to protect him even from
something that doesn't involve politics
and we have to frame it as a way
that makes us not look like we're
desperate so
we'll claim there's a witch hunt
we'll try to dismiss it to the american
public saying oh this is the democrats
going after this guy because they hate
him so much because he's a threat to
their party he's a winner they're losers
even though we all know the opposite
there but that's what they're doing
they're doing it not to protect him
but to protect themselves
and
there's another
pretty significant and very interesting
by the way lawsuit
that also was revealed last week this
lawsuit came from michael cohen
donald trump's former lawyer who
recently completed his three-year prison
sentence
and this one to me is absolutely
fascinating here and if you're not
familiar with it i know david has
actually interviewed uh interviewed
excuse me that was weird michael cohen
um i think a couple times and i think
he's going on michael cohen's show um
but anyway if you're not familiar with
michael cohen's imprisonment
very weird situation right he's in
prison for a year covet hits
and of course trying to prevent the
spread of covid in our prisons they say
okay we can send michael cohen to house
arrest right he's not not a violent guy
clearly not a threat of repeat offenses
here so we can send him home
and he can finish out his sentence there
and they did that
then a couple weeks later they said oh
you know what
send him back to jail but you know don't
just send him back to jail
put him in solitary confinement for a
couple weeks
during which time michael cohen says he
experienced severe health problems
including anxiety
and then finally
after all of this happens a judge comes
out sends michael cohen back home
because as the judge said well here it
is prosecutors insisted probation
officers had been unaware of the
forthcoming book when they wrote a
provision severely restricting cohen's
public communications but a federal
judge ordered him return to home
confinement saying cohen's return to
otisville had been quote
retaliatory
and that is exactly what michael cohen
is alleging in the lawsuit he has filed
which was announced last week against
donald trump alleging that because
michael cohen when he was released from
jail to home confinement the first time
he had been speaking out you know
talking to the press he'd been doing
interviews and he had a book coming out
a tell-all book
and he's alleging in this lawsuit that
trump was angry about this and therefore
the administration pulled some strings
sent him back to jail
and even the judge who looked at this
again because these circumstances were
beyond bizarre
said
this was retaliatory
so when again much like the uh dominion
suit against fox when the judge is
already saying
yeah i mean it really looks like x
michael cohen says you know what then
i'm gonna sue for x
we're gonna do this we're gonna find out
exactly what happened
and i support this lawsuit i would like
to see this again
michael cohen's paid his debt to society
he was sentenced to three years
served as three years
and then that weird little thing in the
middle that made no sense
because they said no you cannot talk to
the press you can't talk to the media
you can't do any of this
uh that's
that's bizarre
it's even more bizarre to throw him back
in prison for it put him in solitary
confinement
for 16 days
something is absolutely fishy here and
i'm glad cohen has filed this lawsuit
because
not only does he deserve answers for
this
but the public does
this could be a potential abuse of power
obviously coming from the trump
administration so this lawsuit would
serve not just to help michael cohen
but also to help the public itself to
find out what the heck happened with
these truly beyond bizarre
circumstances of his re-imprisonment
during a time when the nation was trying
to get as many people out of prison as
possible
to help slow the spread of covid
we've still got a lot more stories to
cover i am farron cousins you can find
me on twitter facebook and instagram at
farron balanced you can also get me on
youtube at youtube.com slash fair and
balanced youtube.com slash the ring of
fire we'll be right back with more on
the david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show welcome back to the
david pakman show i am farin cousins
from ring of fire sitting in for david
pakman all of this week
let's talk about january 6th shall we
obviously in the last few weeks here
we've gotten some
very important news i would call it
about the events of that day the events
before that day the powerpoints the text
messages the emails the phone calls
all kinds of stuff
but some of the most important
information we've gotten about january 6
has actually come from the courts
late last week
the harshest sentence to date for one of
the capitol rioters was handed down the
man who assaulted a police officer with
a fire extinguisher sentenced to a
little more than five years in prison
and of course this individual expressed
his uh
sorrow his sadness
at what he did you know got the
crocodile tears going um
but
judge didn't buy it
still sentence him to more than five
years
and this is
becoming routine at this point
this is what we're seeing happening
with these judges in the sentences that
they're handing down
and here's why and this is very
important and this is something that
everybody needs to understand
about the cases these judges are hearing
because judges are telling us this past
week
that january 6 is it's not over it's not
over
and the reason for that
is because what radicalized these
individuals has not stopped it has not
gone away
while these particular people the the
ones who have been sentenced the ones
who are going to jail are currently in
jail they're probably not as likely to
engage in that kind of behavior in the
future
we're still creating another army
essentially
of these crazed people who think the
election was
stolen and that's what january 6 was
here's another thing
i filled in for david
back in august one of the stories i
talked about at the time i remember it
vividly
was the fact that judges back in august
were telling us
that we're probably facing another
january sixth type six uh situation
because of the radicalization process
because the big lie still persisted out
there
and in fact because it was being pushed
even harder in august than it was in
january
and now here we are four and a half
months after those judges told us that
more judges came out in the past week
and effectively told us the same thing
that we can expect more we can expect
worse
and we can expect this because the
radicalization still exists
because nothing has been done to stop it
because honestly it's hard to stop it
right these people have free speech we
can't tell them they're not allowed to
say these things that's illegal
but they're also not being held
accountable by the media outlets who
allow them to say these things
on their social media platforms where
they spew these lies every day in the
speeches that they give and again part
of this is because there's literally
nothing we can do about it all we can do
is go out there every day and talk about
how this is a lie this is not true all
of the evidence including the
audits and investigations conducted by
conservative groups are all telling us
there's no fraud there was no theft but
even still 70 percent of the republican
party believes joe biden is not the
dually elected president of the united
states
that the 2020 election was stolen 70
percent of republicans believe that now
and if we had listened to these judges
months ago
that wouldn't come as a shock
what happened on january 6th
was kind of an immediate radicalization
of individuals who were most of them
probably kind of already on the edge
they were hardcore supporters they had
their feelings hurt that their guy
didn't win
and then he told them go fight like hell
or you won't have a country anymore
how one of the accused rioters last week
in in in front of a judge said trump
gave me permission to do this
i had a right to storm the capitol
because the former president gave me
permission
so they took that that one statement
from him and well the rest of it as well
that was their action and they went with
it
that's how quickly that radicalization
happened for many of those individuals
for the rest of them we're talking about
radicalization that's been going on for
a year now
radicalization that is taking hold
within the republican party to the point
70 percent look at joe biden and say
that man who i also think is incompetent
somehow stole the election
for the record two things can't be true
there he can't be such an incompetent
idiot you know he can't even stay awake
and a mastermind who stole the 2020
election that makes no sense
yet this is what they believe
and the judges are still out there
warning us that yeah things are going to
get bad again things are probably going
to be worse than what they already were
because nothing's being done
and in many instances there's nothing
legal we can do about it all we can do
is fight back against the misinformation
and as somebody who does do this every
day and i'm sure david feels the same
way sometimes it feels like this
sisyphean task
we're pushing this boulder up the hill
only to watch it roll back down again
and start all over
there's no end there's no there's no
clear victory here
we're just destined to do this forever
to fight back against this conservative
misinformation
but like sisyphus himself we're never
going to stop
it's part of our job it's what we do
it's how we help
so that's what we're doing here
that's what these judges are trying to
do they're giving us the warnings
and if we don't heed these warnings
then yeah we're probably going to be
looking at something much worse than
what happened on january 6th at some
point
in the future
and speaking of january 6 as i mentioned
committees gotten their hands on all
kinds of new events
new communications new text messages new
call logs
and
they recently
got information from ali alexander
himself the man
who's a founder of stop the steel helped
organize this rally you know this was
partially at least his brainchild
and ali alexander has revealed to the
committee that yeah i had communications
with several
republican representatives who some of
them now say like oh i don't remember
ever talking to this guy
but alexander absolutely turned this
information over
to the committee
and said here it is i talked to these
people and the people of course were uh
representative paul gosar a text
exchange with representative mo brooks
and uh also
andy biggs of arizona although he says
he did not
actually talk to him on the phone that
was more of an in-person thing
pretty interesting right so how do we
know aly alexander has given the
committee everything he has
well because that is actually what
alexander is charging in a new lawsuit
because the committee still says we want
your records we want all your records
you you've given us a lot right you know
we asked for these things you've given
us these things but
based on what you've given us
this is kind of indicative that you were
talking to people and so we need to make
sure that you're not holding anything
back
so alexander has sued the committee to
stop verizon his phone carrier
from turning over the rest of his
records
unfortunately purely legally speaking
here
i'm not you know determining alexander's
guilt or innocence in any way
but i will say
having worked with the best lawyers in
this country
for almost two decades now
the argument that alexander is putting
forth to protect his phone records is
about as weak as humanly
possible
alexander is arguing in his lawsuit that
you cannot have all my phone records
because it contains privileged
information
you know my my my conversations with
religious leaders
my religious advice to other people
talks with my clients talks with my
lawyers you can't have that
call log information
or those communications because that's
privileged
that's not a stand-up dude
that's a very very weak legal argument
and one that court case after court case
has shown us
doesn't hold up anyway
this is not to release it to the public
right if it were being released to the
public sure you'd probably have an
argument there
but this is for an investigation for
investigatory purposes and yeah you can
absolutely be compelled to turn over
that information
you know you have very little protection
at that point maybe your communications
with your lawyers could not be turned
over
but everything else absolutely not like
you you have you're gonna have to turn
that over you can't fight that uh very
very weak legal argument here let me
read this from politico
per alexander's the attorneys jonathan
mosley and paul
kaminar members of congress have been on
an organizing call with him in early
january
several were invited but he did not make
attendance the lawyer says
they also said alexander testified he
had phone conversations with
representative brooks staff about a dear
colleague letter
and how his activists could be helpful
alexander said in a sense-deleted video
that he worked with gosar biggs and
brooks to attempt to use congress's
january 6 session certifying biden's
victory as a chance to pressure
lawmakers to overturn the electoral
results
we four schemed up to put maximum
pressure on congress while they were
voting alexander said in the video
biggs and brooks have denied meeting
alexander gosar has appeared at events
with him but has not elaborated on their
relationship
so knowing that
okay and of course the quote from that
now deleted video
do you think
alexander should have to turn over his
entire phone records
is he being honest that look this is all
i have i don't want to give you the rest
of this because you know this is
privileged stuff
or
is there more that we don't know about
how much can we trust ali alexander
now of course that's a subjective thing
if it were me you know just personal
opinion here i don't think i would trust
him
i'm not on the committee i'm not a
lawyer i don't get to make that
determination all i can have is my
personal opinion of him which i just
gave you
so the committee
has a decision to make
do they
just say all right ollie if you're going
to sue us we don't want to get involved
in that whatever you've been a
cooperative person thank you very much
we've got what we need for now we'll
contact you if we need more
or do they fight it and say oh no we
think you've got something to hide
who knows where it goes from here but
honestly
and this is something i was saying since
the early days of this committee
alexander should have been the very
first person they ever asked for
material from
i mean like i said he was the brainchild
of stop the steel you know
why was he not the first if your goal
was to find out what happened that day
why was the organizer of the rally not
the first person
you subpoenaed
to me that makes the committee look bad
that makes it look like they were on
some kind of political hunt
to go after other people first i mean
why was steve bannon
subpoenaed before the guy that organized
the rally that doesn't make sense to me
and just to play devil's advocate for a
moment
if i were alexander that is something i
would bring up in that lawsuit
so
just
throwing that out there
but either way
if he has more information he should be
compelled to turn it over
if it's determined that he is being
honest then okay he shouldn't have to
turn anything else over
he's one of the few people let's be
honest that's actually agreed to go and
cooperate with this committee because he
says you know i don't want to get
involved in all this other stuff and
challenging it and sue blah blah blah
blah so
look
he knows he has everything to lose from
not cooperating with this committee so
maybe you do trust him maybe you don't
it's not my determination to make
because i'm not sitting on this
committee but i will say this in closing
here
i think the committee has their work cut
out for them to the point where it's
time to appoint a special prosecutor to
really take over this because i don't
think the committee is equipped
to keep doing this on their own
we got a wonderful bonus show coming up
for you we've got more talk about covet
a republican lawmakers passed away
we've got donald trump and bill
o'reilly's rally and i'm fair and
cousins thank you so much for tuning in
today i will see you tomorrow and for
the rest of the week right here
on the david pachman show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
if you're looking for a mattress go with
helix sleep their two-minute sleep quiz
will tell you which mattress is perfect
for you you'll get up to two hundred
dollars off and two free pillows at
helix sleep dot com slash pacman